und mit julia rösch macht von der
universität in bonn guten abend will ich
auf diese fraktionssitzung schauen die
sich der heute statt der abgespielt hat
er mir mit wirklich großer spannung der
ahoi seit heute morgen daraufhin
geblickt und dann hieß es na ja gut es
gibt jetzt so diese diesen diesen
kompromiss der beiden parteichefs und
ralph brinkhaus wird dann doch gewählt
für ein halbes jahr so ist es dann auch
gekommen ist das eine gute idee
eigentlich aus ihrer sicht also
strategisch ist es tatsächlich wir haben
gerade den begriff schon gehört man es
auch ein spiel auf zeit es ist der
versuch jetzt ein bisschen ruhe
reinzubringen trotzdem im rahmen dieser
aussprache in der sitzung ein bisschen
ja druck vom kessel zu nehmen der sich
da jetzt seit sonntagabend doch
beträchtlich auch gefüllt hatte in den
eigenen reihen aber es ist natürlich
nicht die lösung für die probleme der
union die bestehen bleiben und da kann
man jetzt auch noch so schön sagen na ja
alles kommissarisch und vorläufig und
man will sich dinge offen halten aber
die wunden punkte bleiben und was wir
was gerd joachim von fiore gerade
zitiert hat nämlich dass armin laschet
ja selbst sagte abgerechnet wird am
wahltag das ist für mich so ein bisschen
die überschrift eigentlich dass man sich
dieser abrechnung und diesen großen
grundsätzlichen fragen jetzt zwei tage
nach der wahl doch noch ein wenig
verweigert sie versucht etwas in den
hintergrund zu drängen sicherlich eben
getrieben von der hoffnung womöglich
doch noch aus der zwei jahre position
aber ist es dann ja auch vielleicht ganz
klug strategisch gesehen jetzt nochmal
erst mal so ein bisschen den deckel
drauf zu halten so weit für das geht
weil viele ich vielleicht von euch der
bisher noch aus unionssicht eine option
ja also da lehrt natürlich auch der
blick in die letzten jahre wie schnell
ist auch mal anders kommen kann wir
erinnern uns an martin schulz und die
spd die sich am abend am wahlabend sogar
vorzeitig
in die opposition brief selbst und dann
am ende doch in der regierung landete
also da hat man sicherlich natürlich
auch ein auge drauf zu überlegen wenn
wir jetzt heute diese entscheidung
getroffen hätten was was sind die
konsequenzen auch wie kann das auch in
der außenwirkung sich darstellen aber
ich muss in der tat sagen die
schlagzeilen der letzten 48 stunden
lassen auch mich erwarten dass die ruhe
ja ich bin ich ein die ruhe vor dem
sturm ist aber
zurzeit wieder wieder hoch köchelt es
ist ein tool macht die macht die union
das dann richtig dass sie gesagt naja
aber mit angela schmid muss das ja in
der fraktionssitzung wohl auch gesagt
haben schreibt der jamaikaner noch nicht
abbaut gibt das man nicht so schnell auf
es gibt starke signale aus der fdp das
war sozusagen in der halb acht und
wartestellung da bleibt ja also formal
ist es ja legitim also man kann auch als
zweitplatzierter eine
regierungskoalition bilden und dann kann
auch man kann auch gratulieren den
wahlsiegern das haben wir heute
aufgehört und das ist auch für mich
eines der beispiele und wir könnten
viele andere nennen die einfach
aufzeigen dass man nach wie vor nicht
mit einer stimme spricht armin laschet
der noch gestern in seiner
pressekonferenz die mit zuwachs
versehenen parteien gratuliert eine ganz
kritische formulierung und markus söder
der jetzt heute sagt man muss wahlsiege
anerkennen und ich gratuliere olaf
scholz und sich damit wieder gegen armin
laschet auch im jahr medial natürlich
wirksam postiert also strategisch ist
man sich offensichtlich trotzdem an
manchen stellen uneins zumindest in der
außendarstellung und auf die kommt es
natürlich in diesen tagen jetzt auch an
und den willen markus söder eigentlich
der
jamaika-regierung haben oder wäre das
schlecht für für sein eigenes bayernland
und fortkommen wenn man da zu viele
zugeständnisse machen müsste also es
wird sicherlich schon darum gehen
zentrale unions politische forderungen
auch einzubringen gleichzeitig das hat
schon am wahlabend angefangen ist man
glaube ich eine hohe leidensbereitschaft
zumindest bei den partei voll bei dem
parteivorsitzenden laschet gemerkt
wirklich vieles anzubieten um dieses
bündnis noch möglich zu machen wir haben
aber jetzt gerade auch wichtige
zwischentöne aus der fraktion gehört die
gesagt hat ohne uns läuft nicht die
markenkern hieß es immer ja die sich
eine machtstellung
hier auch erarbeitet und sagt also da
können jetzt die parteivorsitzenden
machen was sie wollen wir sind auch die
entscheider die am ende mit beteiligt
werden müssen und brauchen ein starkes
mandat in diesen verhandlungen
das ist auch nicht unüblich dass das so
stattfindet aber natürlich merkt man
auch an diesen zwischentönen dass man
also nicht alles was da vielleicht in
den letzten 48 stunden auch von armin
laschet schon angeboten wurde wie so mir
nichts dir nichts in den eigenen reihen
mit geht wie hoch würden sie den hunger
der union auf eine regierungsbeteiligung
einschätzung auf der skala von 1 bis 10
wollte zählt immer noch zu
regenerieren in der opposition das
wilken oder ja also ich denke man
befürchtet einfach was was kommt danach
also sollte ein ampelbündnis entstehen
man landet in der opposition dann steht
man vor allen dingen ja wieder vor
personalfrage personal heißt
parteivorsitz heißt sehr wird dann der
fraktionsvorsitzende muss das in einer
hand liegen und dann ist man im jahr
vier der personaldebatten und das ist
für die union doch
äußerst ungewöhnlich julia rosch macht
herzlichen dank an dieser stelle gerne